last night was discussion so that
everybody could get in it we were free
we had free for all and the theme that I
want to start with this morning is the
one about the fear of getting into the
muck and the relation to images being in
the going to the image because this has
to do with some of your concerns about
imagination in life the relation between
idea and image or something like that
and the question of if you go down if
you get into the mess you may never get
out or it may get worse or something
like that so it's that area that I want
to talk about or address this morning
and I'm going to read some a piece from
interviews and some of you are very
familiar with it but that's that's just
how it is you as a person have to step
back so that the images can come forward
the theory of transference has
overvalued the analyst and in all
therapy one knows that one is a
projected image it isn't only that one
is a projected image image it is that
the analyst is absorbed the imagination
of the patient the analyst has absorbed
the imagination of the patient so you're
always thinking about the analyst
instead of thinking about the dream or
the images even replaced it so his views
and his thoughts well go so the analyst
has to get out of the way that's the
whole problem all the time in everything
and by that I mean whether it's potting
or writing or painting or whatever
that's the whole problem all the time in
everything standing in the way of images
and that's true no matter what you do
see the moment an image comes up and you
interpret it you are standing in the way
of it even in this interview we have to
get out of the way of it so it can
happen by itself with just a little help
here and there from us if you it's just
like analysis
let it come up without so much
personalizing of the analyst or of the
patient they are the means by which
analysis goes on and that's what people
are in the room for see that that's a
crucial thing the two people with your
question the two people are in the room
for the analysis they're not in the room
for the patient they're in the room for
the analysis so that the analysis can go
on not for themselves just like our
conversation now it's for the sake of
the interview not for us can you imagine
being in a conversation sitting at a
table and a Greek cafe and you're there
for the conversation that's where you go
to have a good talk in the evening or in
Calcutta I've read a book once about a
guy who had a who was a babu who had a
job in some office bureaucratic office
and he in the heat he would cycle clear
across town just to sit with four other
guys in the darkroom and talk in the
evenings that that's what that was his
life to be there for the sake of the
conversation and that the conversation
does something then back for you and
it's the personalistic idea that I'm an
analysis for myself that [ __ ] it up
it's that you're in and out you're in
analysis for the sake of the analysis
and that then has a side of side effect
back on you perhaps you are the music as
Elliott says the note of the violin you
are the music as long as the music is on
well you're making the analogy you make
it you've already made it go ahead
if it were Java this was about the
interview if it were just us we wouldn't
know what to say to talk about we don't
have anything really to talk about you
don't know me and it was a fact we
didn't know each other you know we met
to do an interview I don't know you yet
look at the interview it's moving right
along the interview seems to know what
it wants from us you see the analyst is
in the same sort of place
he the analyst doesn't really know that
much doesn't know which way this
person's fate is going to go doesn't
know why these symptoms are occurring of
course he always has clues about it but
he doesn't know as much as the psyche
knows you've got you've got this psyche
knows what it's doing the psyche is not
unconscious we are we patients we
analysts the psyche is constantly making
intelligible statements it's making
dreams and symptoms it's making
fantasies and moods it's extraordinarily
intentional purposive but the system of
therapy has projected the unconscious
into the patient's psyche calling what
the pay what the psyche is doing the
unconscious whereas what's unconscious
is that you can't understand what the
psyche is doing your unconscious then
because of opposites this means that the
analyst must be conscious both patient
and analysts tend to believe this system
the the you you who just asked the
question the normal person the habitual
what we would call the conscious ego
although nobody has ever seen one but we
use that term about the other the
habitual the habitual person the the
person the part of you that you identify
yourself with it gets up in the morning
and eats breakfast and so on and then
has a dream and thinks that's the
unconscious for instance wait a minute
no I missed it
for instance you know of consciousness
floats around sometimes the patient has
an insight and another moment the
analyst is conscious by simply being
reticent and another moment the
consciousness is really in the image for
instance a black snake comes in a dream
a great big black snake you can spend a
whole hour with this black snake talking
about the devouring mother talking about
the anxiety talking about the repressed
sexuality talking about the natural mind
all these interpretive moves that people
make and what is left
what is vitally important is what that
snake is doing this crawling huge black
snake that's walking into your life now
that's a absolutely basic important
distinction between interpretation and
imagination and the moment you've
defined the snake interpreted it you've
lost the snake you've stopped it and
then the person leaves the hour with a
concept about my repressed sexuality or
my cold black passions or my mother or
whatever it is and you've lost the snake
the tasks of analysis is to keep the
snake there a black snake and there are
various ways for keeping the black snake
you see the black snake is no longer
necessary the moment it's been
interpreted and you don't need your
dreams
anymore because they've been interpreted
so you can also imagine that
interpretation reduct
a reductive clarifying interpretations
are a way of getting rid of imagination
and that's one of my complaints about
therapy I'm not saying that's what it
does and has to do and only does but
that's one of the possible complaints
about therapy that it can get rid of
imagination rather than promote
imagination but I think you need them
the dreams all the time you need that
very image you had during the night you
need that very image you had during the
night and you see it's a disturbing
image because in some cultures Eskimo
culture you have several souls and the
soul that dreams is going off somewhere
and doing things and then it doesn't fit
easily with the de world soul so when it
comes back the de world soul doesn't
want to know all this stuff but it
disturbs whatever else you're going to
do and so the feeling that you need your
dream isn't something that we live with
usually we try to fit the dream into the
day world although it comes from another
place
see at night you are in your dream
walking around in it and you feel
yourself to be enclosed in this scene
which is the dream and the moment you
wake up in the morning you say I had a
dream and you think the dream is in you
so you can get the feeling of these two
souls very clearly that way the morning
you believe the dream somewhere in you
in your head or somewhere but at night
you're in the dream the dream has you
and it's hard to move back and forth
between those two feelings yes well
let's let's really go on a little longer
we see what what happens you need that
very image you had during the night for
example a policeman chasing you down the
street you need that image because that
image keeps you in an imaginative
possibility if you say oh my guilt
complex is loose again and it's chasing
me down the street it's a different
feeling because you've taken up the
unknown palete policeman into your ego
system of what you know your guilt you
already know you're guilty and so you
just put the label of guilt on the
policeman chasing you down the street
and then you're comfortable again I mean
you still may feel guilty but you're
comfortable the dream isn't doing
anything upsetting to you it's a
different feeling because you've you've
absorbed the unknown into the known or
made the unconscious conscious and
nothing absolutely nothing has happened
nothing
you're really safe from that policeman
and you can go to sleep again
so rather than this Freud says the dream
protects sleep I think interpretation
protects sleep your interpretation
protects your sleep I want to let the
psyche threaten I want to let the psyche
threaten the hell out of you by keeping
that policeman there chasing you down
the street even now as we talk the
policeman is more important than what we
say about him
now that is so hard for us that is so
hard to realize that a phenomenon is
always more interesting than the
explanation of the phenomenon
explanations are never as interesting as
the phenomenon and the phenomenon the
the only thing interesting about an
explanation is if you take that - as a
phenomenon so we come to the question
what's the point of interpretation or
criticism Europe and how do you do it
and so I mean the image is always more
inclusive and more complex it's a
complex isn't it than the concept let's
make that a rule that's why stick to the
image is another rule in archetypal
psychology so who is the policeman is he
guilt or is he the sense of the law is
he the sense of order is he the sense of
the city the polis has he something to
do with an inherent structure of
consciousness that wants something from
you or reminds you of something or calls
you to him otherwise he wouldn't be
chasing you you need to keep the
policeman there so that you can learn
what he is up to and what keeps you
running and running in the street and
into the street see each of those as a
metaphor running into the street running
in the street being chased are you
chased because are you being pursued
because you're running or are you
running because you're being pursued
maybe the policeman wouldn't chase you
if you stood still but because you're
running you're he has to be chasing and
so on so this all of that play goes on
which which is imaginative play the
images are where the psyche is people
say I don't know what the soul is or
I've lost my soul or whatever to me the
place to look when you feel that way is
immediately to the images that show
where you are with your soul in your
dreams
see what we tend to do is try to get up
and outside and look down on ourselves
and evaluate where we are I'm now 37 and
I'm nowhere with my career or I'm now 46
my wife just left me now so you know you
know where am i what am I going to do
next it's sort of lay it all out from
some some point in how their space
instead of and then I'm lost I don't
know who I am I have no identity and all
of that stuff whereas if you just see
where you actually are not only where
you actually are in the house or the
neighborhood or the physical place you
are but where you are what did you dream
last night that's where your soul is
where what is your mood that's where
your soul my mood is actually I'm
questioning myself I'm trying to find
out who I am that's telling you where
you are that's exactly where you are you
about 400 feet up watching
yes it sends very precise images yes no
it doesn't communicate very well because
you don't usually get it that's not
that's the way I would think about it
yeah it's constantly sending you
messages not messages images images so
could it be a teacher of imagination and
instead of imagining it as a
communicator it is an imaginer and we
keep trying to get the information out
of it and maybe it isn't it maybe it
isn't an information service maybe it's
an imagination service but we're hooked
on information that's a big difference
and then you don't read the dreams for
messages you read them for inspirations
fantasies laughs tears you read them for
other things not for information now we
we absolutely hooked on information we
have to realize that there's more and
more and more information less and less
knowledge they're not they have nothing
to do with each other
[Music]